our disposable syringes are ideal for  dispensing small volumes of liquids lure  slip fitting is slip-on and is held to  the syringe by friction they can be used  on any syringe with a lure adapter  choose lure slip for when you need quick  needle changes and quick to fit lure  lock fittings lock onto the syringe  allowing greater pressures to be pushed  through the syringe without the filter  popping off lower lock filters are only  compatible with lower lock syringes  choose lure lock filters for a more  secured fit and for any application with  high pressure rubber syringes have a  tiny amount of silicone lubricant that  is generally okay for a vast majority of  applications choose rubber free syringes  as a non-lubricant option needles can be  added if puncturing or a rigid tip is  necessary